[Music]  so  you two need a little help  i will give you the best possible chance  of getting pregnant  how does that sound ah that sounds great  am i going to be one of those women who  has it all my career or my kids  my old man by my side who are you going  old  you are 100 pregnant  [Music]  welcome to the family  [Applause]  how are you a little crazy i am  seeing things honey me too i'm having  the wildest mommy brain lately  i don't i don't think it's mommy brain  i think doctrinal did something  i think there ain't on it  in on what  [Applause]  drano gives me a bad feeling i want to  see someone  more natural  there's a lot of voodoo out there we  just want to make sure that you get the  best possible care  forever  whatever it is that's blocking you from  you  i'm not crazy they're trying to make me  think i'm crazy  hey this pregnancy [ __ ] is no joke  right okay it's really scary  right  [Music]  you